Okay.
Now now that we know what we've done this quick review
of such let's talk about
a vectors
so of the word space
really means set.
So why not just say Vector set instead of vector space?
because spaces imply some
sort of
some rules apply
There are some ordering there are some operations you can apply to
the elements on the set. So we try to be more specific.
and
we also want to be careful well.
There's another word here. I want
to use element.
Okay, so they were element.
In the in the context of linear algebra.
we
the convention is not to use the word element in a
set. The convention is to use the word.
Well the scalar.
the scalars of a set
so in linear algebra and element can be
called scalar.
or point
or
component
and it's unlikely free to see elements. So you see these all
the elements elements are all.
synonyms
for members of a
matrix
and of course a vector is a type of
Matrix.
Okay, so these words are interchangeable.
Okay.
So we can call this point point.
or a component component
component element element scalar scalar
scalar
Interchangeable, unfortunately, that's how it is in
mathematics. They use different words to refer to
the same thing.
furthermore
We don't.
use curly brackets
or curly braces the convention is to use either parentheses.
or
square brackets
both are interchangeable.
Okay, let me pull up my notes.
Run asks, which version of python anything version
through your above? Okay. Let me pull up
the
my notes very quickly. Here we go in your algebra.
Okay.
So what is a vector space?
a vector space
actually, no, hold on. I I don't want to jump this is
this is supposed to be vector.
So
vectors
are sets of
elements
however
vectors
are conventionally referred to
as spaces with scalars
Okay.
now
and of course
we use lowercase letters to indicate them.
So like so
and they will either come.
with an arrow on over them like so
Or like I said in our first session it could be
they could be bold like so.
Okay.
so we call the numbers either scalars or components of
the vector
Okay.
we also want to talk about
a linear span linear combination
row space and column space
so we have a linear combination.
And then we can do an exercise.
combination
And we will do.
linear span
and the column space
and then the row space.
And before we do this, we'll also talk about matrices.
So we want to
be clear with our
terminology
Okay. Now let me come to Vector space.
Let me actually borrow it from the chapter of this book because I
thought I had written it here a vector space over the
field.
K with the following axioms
Okay.
The X seems are a vector addition.
Factor multiplication, so let me pause pause
over here and turn the abstract algebra in a
moment.
Okay, here we have it says that a vector space fee
over the field.
What does over mean and what this field mean?
So let's
pause here. I'm gonna open another document to
talk about abstract algebra a little bit.
so this will be
abstract
tutorial one
Okay.
so
I say this will take about 15 or so minutes.
But I mean if you if you do not have exposure to
abstract algebra.
This would this is going to take you along. This
will take you very far.
later on when you
I don't know.
Want to read more advanced probability or go into something
called measure Theory?
Knowledge of abstract algebra will be super beneficials. So
we'll begin with something called a
binary operation
Okay.
so this is
abstract
algebra tutorial
binary operation a binary operation
is some sort of arithmetic operation that it
can apply to the elements of a set.
For example addition and multiplication are both
examples of binary operations.
Okay, so let's establish this terminology
binary operation.
and then we have
our first
special type of set an abstract algebra,
which we call the group.
A group can be expressed.
as the Tuple and again Tuple is a set set curly,
but it's
Okay, not cool three elements.
We would say a triple or three three Tuple
or four tubular five people. So however many elements you have
in that set. You say number two pull.
Okay.
G is the set
and here the start indicates the bunny
operation so it can be multiplication or addition.
Well, we don't we
if there are some certain rules.
We don't use the word. It's quite big and these
are the axioms that apply to the group.
By the way. The group is the foundation. We will build
on top of so other types of sets and abstract algebra
are variations of groups.
We first have something called closure.
What does closure mean?
Clojure means that if you were to perform a binary operation on
the elements of the set.
The outcome would be another element that also belongs
to the set.
So let me actually change this to G.
Okay.
What's an example of?
such a
rule the integers
if we take two integers or let's keep it
simple if you take the natural numbers.
Add them together you will get another natural number.
So 5 plus 5 gives you 10 which isn't which is still an
element within the natural numbers.
Multiply them you will also get another element.
but that division doesn't apply because if you divide
for example
4 over 5 the result is not going to be division. So that
operation does not apply to that set.
Okay.
So there's closure then there's identity.
And identity says that there exists a number.
Such that when you multiply it.
By any of the elements in that set you get the element again.
So here what could what number could that be if we were
talking about the
the integers
What number if we multiplied with any element would give
us the same number? So for example, let's say a is 5.
A times what will give you five?
The number one. So here I stands for then and
this is a unique element.
This is a unique element exactly. What?
So it the identity says that
there exists a number such that multiply by an element
of the set, you know, you get you get the same number and then there is
inverse.
Okay.
We'll see an example of this but there's a number.
the
if you have a number and you multiply it by its inverse.
You will get the that unique identity identity element.
And then there's associativity.
Which says that well, for example, if you're doing
multiplication multiplying eight B times
C and then multiplying it by a it is we'll give you the same.
Result if had you done 8 times B
then times C this associate associated.